P economist John K is author of the new
book culture and prosperity the truth
about markets why some nations are rich
but most remain poor he spoke about it
recently at the city club in San
Francisco California for about an hour
it's a really great pleasure to
introduce John K to you his new book is
culture and prosperity it's a formidable
subtitle is the truth about markets why
some nations are rich but most remain
poor now John is a distinguished British
economist he writes a column in The
Financial Times weekly he has been a
professor at Oxford University a
professor at the London School of
Business and as a continuing professor
at the London School of Economics
however his greatest achievement is that
he spends most of his time living in his
house in the South of France so he has
his priorities right when when I was
told that John was going to be our
speaker and I have the opportunity to
read an economics book I was not that
excited other economics books I've read
I well it tends to call cause mental
dehydration because a little dry often
found they were kind of like protein
bars without water but this book I found
to be absolutely fascinating it's
written with wit and an insight that is
rare almost on every page and I guess
he's turned a protein bar into brain
candy be the best way I'd say it the the
timeliness of this message which really
focuses on how economic systems
political systems and social systems in
a single country are all sort of merged
into a whipped batter and when countries
try to extract one of these elements
whether it's a political system or an
economic system and export it the law of
unintended consequences is at work so
with that let me present John Kay
[Applause]
we'll thanks for your introduction and I
very much appreciate your remarks
because you've described one of the key
things which I was trying to do in
writing this book I have to tell you
that the social life of an economist is
not particularly easy if you meet people
at a party or whatever and have to
reveal you're an economist they will ask
you what do you think what do you think
is going to happen to interest rates and
you can see their eyes scanning the room
as they look round to see if there's
someone more interesting to talk to and
they can make a quick get get away most
people think that that's what economics
is about and that's what economists do
that economists are as it were up and
down what Paul Krugman has called up and
down economists who say that interest
rates are going up inflation is going
down and that that's what the economics
is about for me economics is about
something very different glad I've got
my book back for me economics is about
something very different economics is
about how market economies function and
the book which is available to you in
the United States as culture and
prosperity we published in Europe under
the heading truth about markets we
decided we'd to change it because even
in Britain a book called the truth about
markets was shelved in bookshops along
with books about how to become rich by
day trading and the idea that markets
are basically about securities markets
is kind of now embedded in the popular
context quite consciousness when people
talk about what's happening and the
markets they mean what is happening on
the bond market and the stock market but
actually while I do in the book talk
about the bond market and the stock
market the markets are mainly concerned
about other markets that really make a
capitalist economy work their markets
for flowers markets for a
Chrissa tea markets for milk markets for
oil and you'll find all these markets
discussed in the book as well
so one aspiration I had in writing this
book was actually to offset and
hopefully mellow that popular image of
The Economist I was trying to write a
book that would describe what more
interesting economists really did and
above all I was trying to write a book
that would offer an answer to the
question what is there that we can read
about economics that is aimed at the
same kind of intelligent non-specialists
audience that people write books of
popular science or popular history are
aiming at
so my first objective was to write a
book about economics in that vein but my
second objective I'd had that idea in my
mind for a decade or two my second
objective came about in the last ten
particularly last five years as I
started to see that the market economy
was being presented in a way that
actually simplified simplified its
functioning to such an extent that it
distorted it and that people were being
given a crassly oversimplified and
fundamentally fallacious view of how it
was that market economies worked and
that view of the world which I call the
American business model is something
which you laugh and you're right to
laugh and I will tell you that what I
described in this book as the American
business model is not even a good
description of how it is the American
economy works that is the American
economy is not like that and could not
be like that and the more we make it
like that the worse it is now some
people when I've talked about this in
Europe have told me that when I talk
about the American business model I'm
talking about a straw man I suspect I
don't have to answer that charge in
front of this audience and what I say to
people in Europe is if
you just open the pages of The Wall
Street Journal and look particularly at
the op-ed pages you will find what it is
I'm talking about I'm an economist by
trade I'm a business economist by trade
I'm an economist interested in business
issues and I think I've actually been
rather privileged have lived through the
last 15 years or so because there is
actually no more interesting and varied
time to undertaken the kind of work and
the kind of research which I do let me
just remind you then of some of the
events that have happened during that
period well I would if I could
this
[Music]
what I want to address myself to this
morning is the economic component of the
end of history thesis Francis Fukuyama's
argument essentially that a model of
lightly regulated capitalism with
liberal democracy a model labora
remarkably close resemblance the United
States at the end of the 20th century
that model was not just appropriate to
America in that particular time but was
essentially a Universalist description
of how modern societies should be
organized and that all other systems
were either doomed to fail or were
inevitable transition to that to that
particular model the economic component
of that the wall street journal'
worldview as it were is what I describe
as the American business model and the
American business model as I see it has
four broad components the first that
those of you have studied economics were
recognized as the caricature of rational
economic man that self-regarding
materialism is the dominant motivation
at least as far as economics and
business matters are concerned secondly
a kind of market fundamentalism that
restrictions on the operation of free
markets are almost always costly and as
far as possible should be minimized
thirdly the minimal state that the
economic role of the state should not
extend far beyond the protection of
private property and the enforcement of
privately made contracts and fourthly
low taxation that is taxation and
benefits and society should be limited
to what is necessary to perform these
functions of the minimal state
protecting property and enforcing
contract and to support a basic welfare
safety
but should not extend much beyond that
the minimal state market fundamentalism
rational economic man and low taxation
these are the basic precepts of this
American business model and what I want
to suggest you this morning is that that
description of how a market economy
functions is so oversimplified as to be
seriously misleading and the more we try
and make our market economies like that
the worse not the better they would
perform I'm going to focus then on one
or two aspects of that thesis and I want
to begin with the element of rational
economic man a year or two ago as part
of the work for this book I went in
search of the of rational economic man
of people for whom self regarding
materialism you know was the overriding
motivation I wrote somewhere that self a
rational economic man dies out because
nobody would want to mate with him and
I've come to the conclusion that there's
actually quite a lot in that I started
by going back to the robber barons of
the 19th century john d rockefeller
Andrew Carnegie Carnegie famously wrote
that the man who dies rich dies
disgraced and managed to give away a
rather large proportion of his colossal
fortune before he died it was actually
his scholarships that sent me first to
university as a matter of fact and john
d rockefeller that old hamburger who
knows what his true motives were
famously wrote that the ability to make
money is a gift which has been given to
me by God and it's my religious duty to
get up every morning and exploit it to
the maximum extent that God wishes me to
do so
I thought surely that archetype of
rational economic man in the in the
modern era would be Donald Trump so a
couple of years ago I managed to write
off to an American remainder shop for a
copy of Trump's then out of print
autobiography I'm I see not with great
pleasure that it's now back in print
again as a result of Trump's new success
as a media star but Trump the very first
paragraph of Trump's autobiography the
art of the deal
begins I don't do it for the money I've
got more money than I could ever want I
do it to do it he says deals are my art
form I don't recommend that you read
Trump's autobiography beyond that point
but actually I then went on to Warren
Buffett in a perhaps America's second
richest man you know would exemplify
rational economic man but what Warren
says is it's not that I want money it's
the fun of making money and watching it
grow and I guess that's why Warren still
lives in the same Omaha bungalow that he
bought 50 years ago and why his favorite
night out will come later to some
genuinely rich people's Famer favorite
my doubts but his favorite night at
night out is an evening at the
Nebraskans steakhouse he's been
patronizing for 50 years washed down
with a glass of his favorite tipple
cherry coke it's not that I want money
says Warren it's the fun of what making
money and watching it grow and I was up
in Seattle and redwood yesterday and if
you look into the life story of Bill
Gates you will discover that there is a
certain amount of materialism there I'm
told if you stay at his home which I
emphasize I was not doing if you stay at
his home you can choose which does old
master paintings you want to have
electronically displayed on the wall and
that he can control the temperature of
his waiting bath from the limousine that
takes him back to the off from the
office I have to say even if I had 50
billion dollars
you know these are not the things that I
would spend it on and if you read
Gates's autobiography you will discover
that um I don't recommend you do any
more than I recommend you read Trump's
this is the book you ought to be reading
if you've time to do that but have you
read Gates's autobiography you will be
left in very little doubt that what
fundamentally interest gates is
information technology rather than money
as such and that's why he spends the
money he has in these somewhat to me
peculiar ways the lesson then is that
people who build successful businesses
are not overwhelmingly driven by greed
and materialism and that's not very
surprising actually because building
large and successful businesses involves
a good deal of hard work and it's not
therefore surprising that it's done best
not by people who are passionately
interested in money but by people who
are passionately interested in business
and when you thought through the
implications of that you can also see
some of the damage which we've done over
the last two decades because there are
people who in society who are obsessed
by money to an unhealthy degree they are
to my mind sociopaths they're certainly
not the people who build successful
businesses and they're not the people
who ought to be running successful
businesses and by proclaiming you know
that greed is the overwhelmingly
dominant driver of the market system
what we have done is to attract greedy
people to senior positions in large
corporations that is if you tell people
and design structures around that kind
of motivation one shouldn't be very
surprised that that is the kind of
behavior you get so that actually greed
is not generally an overriding
motivation and when we proclaim it as
such we actually make market economies
work worse rather than work better there
are societies that are characterized by
unrestrained greed and unbridled
opportunism they aren't the rich and
successful societies in which we all
live by countries like Nigeria and AET
and they don't actually work terribly
well so the first group of problems with
this simple caricature of our market
system works are the set of problems
that are to do with the assumptions made
about motivation second group of issues
I'm going to talk about are the problems
which are posed for a market economy by
what it is economists call asymmetric
information now since I suspect at that
point when I come out with a phrase like
asymmetric information you think you're
going to hear one of the talks that will
was describing in his introduction let
me try and liven it up a bit
by offering to auction to anyone in this
room the money which is contained in my
wallet well if you stand back and think
about it you can conjecture speculate
about how much money that might be in my
wallet $50 $100 perhaps suppose you
think it's $50 well you might think of
offering $50 for the amount in my wallet
some of you might be a bit more up to
mistake and offer $80 you could put a
low bid at 10
I bid at 100 supporters actually $50 in
my wallet
what is going to happen of course is
that I'm not going to be very interested
in the $50 bid I'll be very interested
in the $80 bid not at all in the $10.00
bid and very interested indeed in the
hundred dollar bid you can see the
implication of trying to auction the
money which is contained in my wallet
that is the only bids which I will be
willing to accept our bids which it is
foolish for you to make there are no
terms on which it makes sense for me to
sell on which it would be
is for you to buy this is the central
characteristic of a simple market that
is characterized by asymmetric
information and if you think this is a
rather artificial example and it is an
artificial example designed to bring out
clearly the fundamental point you
nevertheless might think back to that
period in 1998 and 1999 when a lot of
people might have been rather better off
if they had asked themselves the
question why does it make sense for me
to buy what it is that this guy wants to
sell to me where there is differences in
information about the value of a
particular commodity it can often be the
case that there are no terms on which
transactions make sense another way
asymmetric information is actually
endemic in a complex modern economy it's
almost always going to be the case that
sellers know more about what it is
they're selling than buyers know about
what it is that I and the market economy
has it's mechanisms that emerge in order
to deal with these kind of problems
mechanisms to do with brands mechanisms
to do with reputations mechanisms to do
with crust relationships that surround
individual transactions just as our
motivation is actually more complicated
than the model based on greed would tell
us and actually just as our economic
activities our economic motives function
because they're bound up with our our
social lives and our volumes so
transactions in a modern economy are
possible in the main only because they
occur within a social context and that's
what we need is that social context that
makes it possible for people to deal
with confidence in a world that is
characterized by imperfect
Meishan now I've already hinted that
imperfect information is a particular
problem in relation to financial markets
and securities markets and when I taught
finance theory to classes at Oxford
University in London Business School I
used to tell them the story that those
of you and I suspect it's most of you
who've done finance courses in good
graduate schools were told the story
about the way in which risk markets and
securities markets worked that risk was
fundamentally a commodity like any other
and the way in which risk markets
functioned was they enabled people for
whom it was expensive to bear particular
risks to transfer these risks to other
people who could bear them more cheaply
well as I say I used to believe that
story in fact I used to teach that story
but I don't believe it anymore and I
want to illustrate the process of my
conversion in with reference to two
moments of epiphany that actually helped
to change my views in a fundamental way
first was in the early 90s when I became
involved with a group of people who were
trying to restructure and reform the
insurance market of Lloyds of of Lloyds
of London which as many of you will know
ran into acute difficulties at the end
of the 1980s a large part of these
difficulties came from something which
became known as the LMX spiral and what
caused that was essentially that people
started writing contracts in the market
in which people agreed to write
insurance contracts that would insure
other people either individuals or
underwriting syndicate against losses in
excess of a certain amount so if the
individual or the syndicate at a loss of
over a certain amount the risk over that
would be taken on by this form of of
reinsurance contract and these kind of
contracts proliferated in the mark
it during the period what went wrong
with this story well the story went fine
for a bit because no claims were made on
these contracts it was essentially money
for old rope the things started to go
wrong when in the late 1980s the market
suffered a series of very large gatito's
catastrophic claims the first big claim
of this kind was when Piper alpha one of
the oil rigs in the North Sea you know
went on fire you know 150 people were
killed and there was a Oh more than
billion dollar insurance claim from the
rig operator occidental against a
against Lloyds in relation to that what
happened was that that claim started
triggering these reinsurance contracts
and what happened as a result of the
triggering of reinsurance contracts is
that triggered the same contracts for
the syndicates and the individuals who'd
written these reinsurance so claims
started triggering each other round and
round the market until the original 1
billion of claims gave rise to a total
of 16 billion dollars of claims in the
market as a whole and what it turned out
was that the people who were at the top
of the spiral the people would reinsure
the reinsurers of the reinsurers what
they had in fact done was insured the
same risk the risk of the piper alpha
disaster over and over again with the
result that these insurance contracts
far from spreading the risk about around
the marketplace focused it on a
relatively small number of individuals
and syndicates none of whom had the
least idea of the nature of the risks
they had ultimately taken on and the
moment of Epiphany I described came when
I asked a group of underwriters who had
denouncing vigorously the incompetence
of the people who've been playing the
market in that wager in the period ask
them if these people were as bad as you
say they were why didn't you blow the
whistle
and their answer of course was to say
because they were willing to buy risks
at prices at which I was very happy to
sell them and what I saw had been going
on in the market during that period was
what our sins come to see as an exemplar
caricature of what goes on in financial
markets as a whole in which transactions
occur like the wallet auction like the
asymmetric information story knot in
which people who can bear risks for whom
the cost of beer is bearing a high
transfer them to people who can bear
them more cheaply but in which people
who know quite a lot about what they're
doing transfer a variety of risks to
people who know less about what they're
doing and that the process of doing that
bids up the costs of operating in the
market as a whole now when I took this
theory the second part I used to teach
was to say if you don't believe that
markets work like that you have to
believe they're like that because that
they weren't people who behave
rationally would make money at the
expense of people who behave
irrationally and that's indeed the
underpinning of the argument for modern
finance theory as a basis for financial
markets I now still believe that if
people who don't if people behave
irrationally they lose money to behave
people pay more rationally but what I
now believe is that yes that is exactly
what goes on in a lot of the risk
markets which we have and I came to see
that more clearly and another bizarre
occasion in my life London is one of the
two or three centers of the world we're
really high rolling gamblers go to lose
money there are half a dozen casinos in
London which are the kind of places
where people can go that the sorts of
people go who go who are so rich and so
addicted to gambling that if they lose a
quarter of a million dollars in an
evening that's something they can
cope with quite easily and do quite
frequently and these six claps
incredibly opulent places most of them
in Mayfair in London are where this kind
of gambling occurs now for bizarre
reasons I spend an evening in which I
was driven from one of these clubs to
the other and I learnt quite a number of
things in the course of the evening but
the one that most surprised me was that
I'd expected these to be jolly places
where people were having fun and the
people who were doing it had so much
money that if they lost a quarter of a
million bond in an evening having a good
time it didn't really matter to them but
they weren't in the main having a good
time they were sitting there grim-faced
white-knuckled watching the roulette
wheel spinning are the cards fall and
this seemed to me and still does quite
old the majority of people in these
clubs are actually people who are
successful entrepreneurial business
that's how they acquired the kinds of
fortunes which enable them to engage in
this kind of activity and yet there were
these successful entrepreneurial
businessman sitting there not just once
but evening after evening genuinely
believing that they were going to win at
Roulette and continuing to maintain that
belief despite repeated evidence that in
fact they didn't how could this be well
as I thought about it afterwards the
elements of the explanation you know
have come to me yes these people are
irrationally optimistic most successful
entrepreneurial business men are
irrationally optimistic there are people
who have taken on risks that sensible
business school trained people like you
and me you know would not dream of
taking on and which we would be right to
take on but for not to take on but for
some of these people you know these
risks come on
there are other people more people for
whom they don't come off but they're not
the people you see in Aspen holes in the
Clurman Club they're the people who are
running a garage you know having gone
bankrupt in three previous ventures to
do the same the people we see in Aspen
homes are the people who are drawn from
a very small upper tail of the
distribution but these are the people we
recognize as successful entrepreneurs in
the modern economy in other words what
I'm saying is that the functioning of
capitalism actually depends on a
constant supply of people who are
irrationally optimistic and it is from
these people that a large proportion of
the innovation both technical and
organizational that makes our market
economy function actually comes so that
this these models I used to teach in in
in economics courses and business
schools about rational economic behavior
don't describe very well this underlying
dynamic of the capitalist economy nor do
they describe well the operation of
financial markets which are in large
part institutions designed like blood
play the casino is to take some money
off these kinds of people and
redistribute it to more rational
thoughtful people like those of us in
this particular room in securities
markets in other words what generally
dominates these markets is that people
sell risks to other people who know less
about the risks that are being taken
that are being taken off it's a
different model from that one which I
used to teach and in understanding how
it is that capitalist economies depend
on the supply of irrationally optimistic
people we start to get towards what for
me is the real dynamic
of a market economy which is what I call
discipline pluralism when I described in
the book is a comparison of some of the
elements of central planning versus the
market economy I Allah straight central
planning through a variety of examples
one of the classics of which is the
story of crew scoffs maze in 1958
Khrushchev as the Cold War started to
thaw after the death of Stalin
Khrushchev paid a visit to the United
States it's a very bizarre visit in a
lot of ways one of the highlights was
when he and his aides went to a
supermarket and they went away believing
that the shelves had all been specially
stopped up you know for their arrival as
would indeed have happened if the
President of the United States that have
visited a supermarket in the Soviet
Union but what made the biggest
impression on Khrushchev was when they
went to Iowa and they were taken to see
the maize fields of the prairies there
was clearly no faking the fact that the
crops of maize stretched into the
distance or as far as the eye could see
and Khrushchev returned to Russia
persuaded that the future of Soviet
agriculture rested on maize so a large
part of Soviet wheat production was
converted to maize the experiment it
must be said was not a success there
were good reasons why it was wheat
rather than maize that was the
traditional crop but this was not what
Khrushchev was told he was told that the
experiment was going well and to the
extent that it wasn't it was because of
sabotage by people who were
insufficiently committed under socialism
one of his acolytes famously said maize
can be grown anywhere
but it couldn't and the reduction in
Soviets agricultural production was
actually one of the reasons for the
economic setback that eventually led to
led to Khrushchev being toppled from
power now the idea of experimenting with
maize in the Soviet Union was not a bad
idea what was wrong was two things one
was the scale of the experiment if an
individual Soviet farmer had gone to a
Mary and been impressed by maize he
would have gone home planted one or two
fields of maize if the experiment had
failed that would have been the end of
it if it had succeeded other people
would have imitated the experiment in
Russia was undertaken on a much larger
scale and also there was no honest
feedback about it the process by which
people tell their superiors how well
their ideas are going as they're
implemented in practice is one which I
suspect is familiar not just in the
Soviet Union but to most of you in this
room who've spent any part of your your
working careers in large corporations
it's the combination of scale of
decision making and the absence of
honest feedback in contrast with the
story of discipline pluralism which is
it best exemplified going back to
Redmond by the evolution of personal
computers in the United States the key
thing about the story of the computer
industry in in America is that there
wasn't any single voice it's actually
the product it's not the product of the
vision of Bill Gates or Steve Jobs or
any other heroic individual indeed most
of the experiments which were made in
the course of the development of pcs
failed even most of the most of the
experiments which turned out to be
technically important to the development
of the industry failed for failed
commercially for the people who
implemented them and pioneered them
probably the company which has made the
single most important contributions to
the development of pcs was Xerox which
manufactured in 1973 the first thing
that anyone would recognize as a
personal computer and later invented the
graphical user interface the systems are
mouse and icons which produce the key
development that we now have computers
that you don't have to know anything
about computers in order to be able to
use but Xerox failed commercially with
both of these and and in terms of
profits Xerox gained nothing out of
being such an important contributor to
the personal computer revolution
discipline pluralism is for me the key
attribute of a more market organization
a system in which there is extensive
experiment and in which unsuccessful
experiment is ultimately cut cut off
it's the process that is motivated by
the kind of irrationally optimistic
entrepreneurs I was describing earlier
the people I saw amass panels and the
clairement so I want to argue that how
market economies function is a more
complex story than the one which is told
in the American business model not only
a more complex story but a much more
interesting story as well I'm going to
pass briefly over the slides which I
brought to America to annoy people
which are the ones in witches will
describe earlier I spend most of my
working life now in France and I have
this set of slides that explains how the
French economy is actually in many
respects superior in terms of its
performance to the American one I won't
develop that thesis at least at this
time this morning what I will do simply
is to take this illustration you know of
a French market to emphasize that
markets function by virtue of their
social context motivation needs to be
seen in a social context market
institutions deal with a range of
problems like information asymmetry
through the variety of reputations and
trust relationships that surround the
operation of a market economy we can
deal with people with confidence because
we develop relations between them and
it's relationships not contracts that
actually enforce the transactions and
the activities of the market economy the
market economy which we have today in
the 20 or so rich successful societies
of the world is the product of two
hundred years of coevolution of
institutions technology politics and
society and it's essential and central
that all these things have evolved and
developed together and it's when we
understand that that we understand why
simple attempts at mimicking the
institutions of a market economy fail
and why when we go to Russia or Iraq or
to some of the poor countries of the
world with a belief that there's a
simple manual of our market economy
functions and if you only follow that
you will develop successful economic
institutions why these attempts not only
fail but fail by orders of magnitude
without that kind of simultaneous
evolution of social cultural political
institutions with market institutions
market institutions will not actually
function effectively you may have seen
on one of the history slides with which
I began this presentation the slogan
capitalism will be should be replaced by
something nicer a slogan which we took
we saw on the banners of some of the
Mayday protesters in London a couple of
years ago I think it encapsulates better
than better than I could in much longer
sentences the basic incoherence of
today's modern critics of capitalism but
it's not very surprising that market
economies and capitalism are unpopular
if we describe capitalism and market
economies as encouraging people to be
very greedy and imposing as few
restrictions on what as possible on what
they do that's not just not how a market
economy works it's not even a possible
description of how a market economy
could be made to work and the more we
make our real market economies like that
the worse they actually function the odd
thing that has happened in my mind in
the 10 15 years since the end of the
Cold War is that we presented those of
us in economics and business we've
presented to people outside a
description of the market economy that
is succeed simultaneously in being both
repellent and false when capitalism
should be replaced by something nicer I
want to suggest that that nicer thing
with which capitalism should be replaced
is actually a better description of how
it is that a market economy actually
functions thank you all very much
you'll notice on your seat that there
are plenty of pins and if any of you
have questions if you'd write them down
right now and and pass them down to this
edge they'll be collected or to either
edge they'll be collected and we'll have
a chance to ask John at least some of
them and John I want to start off with
some questions that I got from your book
and as these other questions come in the
first one is that your book seems to say
that rich societies have cultures that
and political systems that support
mutual benefit and that poor societies
don't and I'm wondering if you could
illuminate what some of the what that
mutual benefit ethos is and and how it
works in some cases and not in others
there are loads of elements to the
coevolution of institutions that I've
described that makes up a market economy
these range from what perhaps for me is
one of the most fundamental requirements
of the successful market economy which
is what I describe as disinterested
government that is that the nature of
government should cease to be what it
has been for most of history and still
is in most countries of the world today
a mechanism by which the people who gain
control of the government are able to
gain control of the resources of the
country for their own benefit the
transforming element that made a market
economy possible or certainly without
that transforming element it could not
have become possible was the
developments of systems of government in
Europe in the United States that didn't
have that kind of characteristic and we
all know even from the United States
today that actually maintaining
disinterested government of that kind is
something that damar
constant vigilance so that's a one
prerequisite but equally let me go from
the sublime to the ridiculous if you go
and have a beer after work in a bar
you'll be handed a glass of beer that
means you're entitled to the beer but
you're expected to give the glass back
you can also sit at a table but your
right to sit at a table is something you
have to replenish from time to time in
the course of an evening by buying
another drink another round of drinks
it's also very common as you know to
engage in this practice of buying rounds
of drinks now we know all these things
but if you imagine coming from Mars you
know and go walking into a bar or even
imagine yourselves coming from a you
know as a subsistence farmer from a poor
country and finding yourself in a bar
you would not know all these things you
would have to have them explained to you
and that's just a very simple example of
how every transaction we engage in in a
market economy even the most basic you
know like getting something to drink is
surrounded by a set of social rules and
conventions that have evolved over
hundreds of years that we all take for
granted but we shouldn't take for
granted because to create a successful
functioning market economy you have to
create all these rules and conventions
and that's why you can't write the
simple manual what has to be as you
describe a blended mixed well the next
is a question you're going to love how
would you advise bush or in the event he
has a successor to develop Iraq's
economy
right well I'm sure you all know the
Irish directions of if I was going there
I wouldn't start from years I mean it is
quite hard and I still find it slightly
hard to credit you know the naivety of
the belief which genuinely does seem to
motivated at least some supporters of
that intervention that there is a very
simple story about how liberal democracy
and market economies work and not only
that everyone wants these things they
want the results of these things it's
not so clear they want the institutions
that everyone wants these things and if
they only only they read the book they
will be able to set up these
institutions we can't design a set of
market economy and democratic
institutions for Iraq or for for any
other country and those countries like
perhaps my own that have a longer
history of imperialism than the United
States have learnt that by painful
experience you know decades ago so it's
not it's not a possible opportunity for
America to create a functioning market
economy in Iraq that has to be very
largely done by the Iraqi people
themselves in order to achieve that a
whole variety of other political and
cultural preconditions need to be in
place and that development is something
that will you know will take a very long
time the notion that we could establish
as it were a beacon of market economics
and democracy in the Middle East from
which everyone else would learn was
simply a very naive mistake that's not
an answer but it's it's a response
that's great just stay with us here if
you were going to try to give advice to
third world countries or developing
nations you mentioned in your book
there's a relatively few that are really
prosperous on on a growth track what
advice would you give their their
leaders I mean the answer once again to
that is this is a lengthy process of
coevolution you know and it can't be
very easily kick-started we hat right I
described in the book the remarkable
fact that they're not very into me many
intermediate countries in the world
there are as I described about 20 or so
rich countries there's a mass of poor
countries and there are very few in
between there are some of the poorer
countries of Europe like Greece and
Portugal countries like South Korea and
Taiwan which are on the way up to being
rich states but they're not very many of
these intermediate countries and the
reason is that you need all these sets
of preconditions in place in order to do
it now the most optimistic area for
development has been and is Southeast
Asia and that's in large part because a
lot of these other conditions you know
were already in place in a sense and
risk the way I put it in the book one of
the biggest questions of economic
history one of the biggest difficulties
is to understand why it was that two
three hundred years ago economic
development took off in Western Europe
rather than South East China because in
many technological resource respects
these societies at that time looked
similar so in some sense is when we look
at China today we are not led to be
surprised less that their current growth
rate than at the fact that China has
actually been so poor for so long an
observation which is reinforced by
noticing our successful Chinese people
have been economically outside China
whether in Hong Kong Singapore
taijuan or in the united states and
britain so that to reinforce again the
point that we need all these political
cultural conditions to be a right to be
in place poor countries have to develop
like the iraqis these institutions for
themselves over period a long period of
time we can give them bits of advice we
can also give them specific humanitarian
assistance but there are very large
limits to what we in rich countries can
do and it's an important observation to
make but another one that demands
another lengthy answer that we are not
rich in rich countries because poor
people in poor countries are poor or
vice versa
and it's very important that both rich
and poor should understand that and that
what makes us in rich countries so
prosperous is essentially the high
levels of productivity that we enjoy
domestically John one of the
observations you make in the book is
that Americans lead the world in
personal consumption by a very large
measure and also they also lead the
world in the shortest vacations of
longest working hours and I'm wondering
if you might comment on that and how
that might have come to be and you're
inviting me to get into the the America
versus France story let me let me give
you a little bottom line on that which
is to say that I don't expect many
Americans to believe this but
productivity in terms of output per hour
is actually higher in France than it is
in the United States however personal
consumption in the United States per
head is 60% higher than that of France
now a whole variety of factors lead to
that difference you know right one is
that the Americans run a very large
trade deficit you as a nation consume
consider
more than you produce and the French
don't another is that government
expenditure in France is a lot higher
than it is in the United States but the
largest difference is the comparison in
working hours and let me simply give you
you know these figures to illustrate
well to remarkable facts one is how much
longer it is that people work in the
United States than they do in European
countries the other is that while in
almost all European countries the number
of hours which people work has been
falling quite fast right in the United
States average working hours has
actually been going up and the United
States is actually a complete outlier in
this both in the length of time people
work and live in the fact that it's
rising all experienced from elsewhere in
the world is that the richer people get
the less work they do there are three
parts to what's going on one is
Americans of longer working weeks and
other that Americans have less holiday
and another is that Americans retire
later you know one American man in -
between 60 and 65 is working one
Frenchman and six between 60 and 65 is
working amazingly to a European one
American man in six between 70 and 75 is
working I think the only Frenchman over
70 was working is President Chirac and
the only reason he's continuing to do it
is that if you left the Alesi Palace
it's very likely he would leave it to go
to jail you know as the corruption
investigations around him gathered pace
you know these Arora will write the
these are very different social choices
but if you want a simple explanation of
the difference between French and
American economic performance it is that
the French take lunch and have five
weeks holiday
thank you John it's time to conclude and
I first of all I want to say thank you
to John Kay and
we appreciate you coming all this way
just for us John we'll be in the back
signing books after after we break up
from here I'd also like again to
acknowledge our sponsors BearingPoint
graduates club the Johnson School of
Management at Cornell University and of
course Business Week we look forward to
seeing you next time when Deepak Chopra
will speak on the soul of leadership
John Kay is a professor at the London
Business School and the University of
Oxford he writes a weekly column for the
Financial Times culture and prosperity
is published by Harper Business an
imprint of HarperCollins visit
HarperCollins com for more information